hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
answering the question what is an allele
and how is it different from a gene
before we launch into that i want to
remind you that you can get
a final picture of the board with all
the notes filled in for study purposes
for free
by clicking on the tiny url in the
description below so make sure you get
your free pdf for study purposes
um
and also remember to subscribe so let's
go ahead and get started alleles versus
genes first i'm going to talk about
alleles but they are
compared to genes and then i'm going to
throw in a little bit of the discussion
about homozygous versus heterozygous and
dominant versus recessive for those who
need it
so
let's go ahead and get started by
talking about what a gene
is now a gene
is a segment of dna that codes for a
specific trait so imagine your dna it's
this you know these these huge
chromosomes
that are
very very long sequences of nucleotides
remember those letters atcg that's
adenine thymine cytosine guanine
and there are you know segments like
discrete units of the dna
that code for a specific trait that's
what we call a gene
now how does it code for a specific
trait what is that mechanism well the
dna the genes
are the templates
for either
proteins
or functional strips of rna
so i think students are generally pretty
familiar with
messenger rna transfer rna ribosomal rna
that's the mrna trna and rrna that you
learn about when you learn about
transcription and translation but there
are a lot of other types of rna that
have many different functions
particularly regulatory functions so
things like link rna
micrornas
snrnas
si rnas so if you want to learn more
about that i've got a video called
regulatory rnas that goes into more
detail on those different types of rna
now let's get on to the reason i think
most of you are here and that is what is
an allele and how is it different from a
gene well
an allele
is an alternative
version of a gene
so for example if you've learned about
the work of gregor mendel working with
his pea plants you'll remember that he
was looking at the flower color
gene of course mandel didn't know what
dna was and he didn't have the word for
gene
but he was looking at the sort of the
flower color character
and saw there were there were
alternative versions so the pea plants
could have white petals or they could
have purple petals and now we in the
21st century have the benefit of a lot
more knowledge than gregor mendel
and we know that the flower color jean
comes with two different versions so
that the um the gene can either be
coding for a white petal color or a
purple petal color depending on the
specific sequence of nucleotides that
were inherited
by that plant from its parents
another example if you want a human
example is for tasting the chemical ptc
so ptc
is a chemical that some people when they
taste it it tastes you know horribly
bitter because they have the allele for
tasting
um or there's also a non-taster allele
so a person who has non-taste or alveoli
can touch that ptc to their tongue and
not taste anything really
so that's another example of alternative
versions of the gene
now i want you to be aware
that
in
sexually
reproducing
species
um like humans for example individuals
are going to have usually two copies
right there are some plants that will
get more
more than two copies but generally if we
think about humans and other animals
um individuals are going to have two
copies
each of those copies being an allele so
two alleles
for each gene one from each parent so
um a person if you go back to this ptc
example can get you know a taster allele
from both parents or a non-taster allele
from both parents or you can get a
taster allele from one parent and a
non-taster allele from their other
parent
so
in most cases individuals have two
copies or two alleles for a gene
if the individual
has
two of the same
allele
so for example two of the taster alleles
let's say or or a pea plant it has two
uh white alleles
that is known as being a homozygote
so a homozygote or a homozygous
individual
speaking specifically about that locus
right because when you have
thousands of genes you can be homozygous
and some and
if the individual has two
different
alleles
for a given gene that is called being a
heterozygote
so again if we go back to our example
with the pea plants with the flower
color gene you could have plants that
are homozygous for you know having
two of the purple alleles for the flower
color gene but then be heterozygous for
some other genes say for
um you know seed color or seed texture
or plant height so
the homozygous and heterozygous
descriptors
are going to be just talking about
whether the alleles are the same or
different at a specific locus so for a
specific gene
um now let's talk a little bit about
dominant and recessive so some alleles
that are called
dominant
alleles can mask other alleles and the
alleles that get masked are called
recessive
alleles now i want you to understand
that this is kind of an
oversimplification
like yes there are traits
there are alleles that are dominant and
they completely will mask a recessive
allele but not all traits are that
simple you can have examples where there
are you know alleles that are
co-dominant with each other or where
there's kind of um an incomplete
dominance and like a blending sort of
effect and so this is you know true for
certainly for for many genes but not
true for all
and i just want to give some examples
here if you have we're talking about pea
plants again pea plant that has two
dominant so i've used capital letter p
here
to
dominant alleles homozygous meaning two
of the same and they're dominant this is
going to result in a purple flower color
um
if a pea plant is heterozygous at that
flower color uh locus meaning there's
one dominant allele
and one recessive allele well the
dominant allele totally masks the
recessive and you only see the color
that comes from that dominant allele and
that is purple
so you see there are two different um
types of alleles
that give the same what we call uh
phenotype so the color here the purple
that
is going to put that in parentheses over
here phenotype
is
what you see what you observe whereas
i'm going to put it in parentheses over
here genotype
is the specific combination
of alleles that results in that
phenotype
now if you have a pea plant that has
only two of the recessive and there's no
dominant around to get that purple color
these would be homozygous remember
homozygous two of the same allele and it
happens to be in this case the recessive
allele and so these will be
white
and so that shows you that that
recessive color only comes out when
there's no dominant allele to mask it
so i know that was a lot i have a
playlist on mendeley injects it has six
videos in it that's it just six videos
these six videos together have about
half a million views so please check
that out if you're studying mendelian
genetics you can learn about punnett
squares with monohybrid crosses and
dihybrid crosses you can learn about a
test cross and you can review three
major laws from the work of gregory
mendel his law of dominance his law of
segregation and his law of independence
assortment these last two number five
and six here i believe that they're both
approaching 200 000 views just on their
own so definitely check those out
remember
that you can get a free pdf of the board
notes by going to the tiny url in the
description below
make sure you subscribe and thank you
for watching join me next time for more
biology study videos
and until then good luck with your
studying